I just want to take a second on my guy
Tyreek Hill saying he's the lion and he
said he got something for me coming off
the edge hold on wait a minute Tyrique
wait a minute Tyreke I'm letting you
know there's a big difference between me
and those other guys that you coming off
the edge with I listen to Rick if you
come over my way and I see you coming my
way I'm sending you to the tent I'm
sending you to the sideline you're gonna
say hey coach I want nothing to do with
Michael Parsons you don't want to do
that hey I already said it once and I
said on social media my baby girl's
getting cheetah print for for Christmas
she's getting cheetah print come over
here to my site and with my baby girls
getting cheetah print but all of my guy
what you doing right now you really
showing that you
let's argue about it if your wide
receiver won is Tyreek Hill wide
receiver one I mean we see what he's
doing we see what Justin Jefferson's
doing
um who who's wide receiver one how are
you going to argue it these guys are
lighting illegal right now but the
difference is the Dolphins are 3-0 the
Vikings are all in three
you know uh
who's gonna argue it right now right now
we have to give it Tyree kill he's he
has to be the best wide receiver uh in a
league because he's making the most
impact
um
so let me get back into and then before
I get to that I want to say how we stack
up against the Dolphins honestly it's
going to be a hell of a matchup on
Christmas Day I can't honestly I can't
wait uh to to you know go through it
with these guys it's gonna be a war day
um and it's going to be a very exciting
uh obviously I think the Dolphins have
the most explosive and I'm explosive I
say speed uh
in the NFL I mean I don't know where you
stacking against the Bengals who has the
best uh group between the Bengals and
the Dolphins but wide receiver in court
they have both of the best teams however
you want to argue if you want speed or
you want guys to go up in Mars because
that's what Jamar chasing T Higgins do I
mean they just gonna go get it so
however you want to argue it I think
those guys are the best uh